And very often data can tease that out,
we can learn how important price is
to the customer,
how important delivery time is
to the customer.
How many, you know,
I think a big part of any marketplace
is understanding that balance
of supply and demand
and how to not just like, forecast it,
but also act against it.
Peter Fishman,
thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you today?
Doing well.
Calling from California?
I'm in San Francisco.
San Francisco. Lots to cover,
let's get into it.
A fascinating, fascinating journey.
I don't know how many more people
I've had in this show
that have so many different experiences
as you've had.
I even have to open it up
next to me in order to read it
which I have.
I don't think I've ever had
to do that before.
All the way starting
from studying economics
at a London School of Economics
to doing your bachelor
also at Duke. University of California,
Berkeley, doing your PhD.
And then you're moving
to NERA Economic Consulting, Google,
Philadelphia Eagles,
the Parthenon Group,
Playdom, economist in Walt Disney,
director of analytics at Yammer,
principal data science manager
at Microsoft,
VP of analytics and growth at Zenefits,
an amazing company.
Head of analytics at Opendoor,
chief bacon officer at Bacon Hot Sauce.
You also have to explain to me what that is.
And most recently,
your are chief strategy officer of Eaze,
a company that
a lot of our friends in California
will know what it's about
and you'll explain to us soon.
And now, the co-founder
of your own company, Mozart Data.
Did I get any of that right?
Or am I completely off?
It's a nice walk down memory lane.
But, yeah.
I spend a lot of different companies
and a lot of different careers
with some common themes there.
I need about 19 minutes of breather
after reading that list.
Peter, what the hell.
How does a person
go through a list like this?
How does that happen?
Yeah. Well, so,
I think you hit on one thing.
I'm an economist by trade.
So, I did my PhD in economics
in the bay about eight miles east
of where I'm currently living
at UC Berkeley.
It was a really special time
to be in behavioral economics
and applied behavioral economics.
And I was working with a lot of data
and sort of getting that training
and sort of teasing causality
out of a data set
and trying to understand
what's driving certain things
that are happening simultaneously,
is a really interesting tool set
that I learned in graduate school.
And then there was sort of
this really nice movement towards
using more and more and more data
as it became more ubiquitous
in tooling and decision making
and then more and more cost effective
so that organizations beyond
just the giant tech companies
could really use data
to advance their decision making.
And that's kind of been
a common thread of my career.
Right. I mean, you can literally see
the thread as you're transitioning
from being an economist
and an analyst at these companies
to then running
the analytics and growth,
but then transitioning
into strategy in data science.
And then most recently,
the company that you're running now,
Mozart Data, which we'll talk
about it soon,
is really helping companies
analyze the data, pretty much the work
that you've been doing across
about a dozen
of these fantastic organizations.
But, Peter, before we get to Mozart Data,
I'll leave that for the second half.
I'd love to pick your brain
on these nuggets and experiences
from these different companies.
As an economist,
what is the role of an economist
within these tech organizations?
And when I look at also Walt Disney
I think of it as a technology company
like any other.
So, a lot of larger companies
have economists that opine
on the direction of the economy
because so much
of the investment of people
and resources depends on like
basically the bigger
macroeconomic picture.
That's actually not at all what I do.
An economist in my mind
is about using an economic toolset
to understand data.
So, thinking about
kind of some of that training
and some of that
sort of micro economic decision making
and how that impacts
the sort of macrovision of a company.
So, I think a lot of what I do,
though, my title is often economist
and then my training as of to economist,
I'm just an applied statistician
that happens to have taken some
economics classes.
So, I think with that,
Yeah. So, I think there's,
the common theme there is
that economists have a really good way,
in my mind, of thinking about
causality and prediction.
Of modeling data. Right?
Yeah.
Of thinking about kind
of the relationship between two things
that are happening.
And that's because
data used to be a lot smaller.
So, when I did my PhD,
I had a giant giant,
giant, giant, giant data set,
which was about
half a million observations.
Today, if we saw a data set
of half a million observations,
it would be, you know,
it would be of events that people
might have picked up in minutes
or even less.
So, what used to
sort of count as a giant data set
is now a very, very trivial data set.
And but because data was small,
you had to think of really clever ways
of understanding the world
and understanding relationships
in the data.
And sometimes that meant things
like describing a mechanism of behavior
that would sort of account
for these two things,
covariance with each other.
And sometimes that would be actually
sort of these fake experiments
that would be existing in the data.
They weren't real experiments.
They weren't like
scientific method experiments
where you try condition A,
and condition B and see
which one's the winner,
which is so prevalent
in today's A/B testing
and other forms of testing.
But rather, things that were
sort of almost a natural experiment
that would occur in the data,
and you would have small data
and you'd want
to tease out that causal relationship
and think about in a deep way
about in what ways
is this not a real experiment.
So, that training, I think,
really helped as we transitioned
at smaller tech companies
from essentially small data
to almost everybody having big data
due to a lot of cost efficiencies
that have come up on the data side.
That transition from an economist
or an analyst to running analytics
to being head of analytics,
head of growth,
both at Zenefits and then at Opendoor,
how is that transition?
What is the thinking process?
Because to me, it sounds like
it's a little bit even more dramatic
than being an engineer
to a head of engineering.
Here, you're really,
because you keep saying,
economists is the thinking of causality
and what impacts
in modeling data to see trends.
And in one hand, you're modeling
you know, a subset of the data
as in your position,
it sounds to me like
being head of analytics
is now thinking much more broadly
about, okay, where are we headed,
what can we extrapolate from the data,
and what can we request
from the engineering
to provide us for the future?
Yeah.
So, my first year at graduate school,
I read Moneyball,
which was for many folks
in the analytics industry,
that was a very sort of defining book.
It's Michael Lewis's book
on the Oakland A's
and I was going to graduate school,
just one town north of Oakland.
And then ultimately, I became
sort of the Moneyballer
at the Philadelphia Eagles.
Which is I use my graduate training
to pull out sort of insights
about players and football activity
at the Eagles.
And what I learned there
was really about
impact across an organization,
which is very often
there can be an insight.
Like it's good to go for two
when you're down by 14.
Or, it's good to trade out
of the first round.
Or something that the data clearly,
or it's good to go for it on fourth
and short, whatever it is,
the data might back that out
and might be convincing
in an academic way,
but there's real people.
And you don't get to really run all
the experiments you want
in the real world.
And sort of having
a big impact across an organization
is not just about teasing out
the insights and the data,
but it's also about
kind of driving impact
within the organization.
You're making it happen, right?
Exactly.
So, you had mentioned
a few transitions, right?
I transitioned from being
an individual contributor
at a company like Playdom and Disney,
to being sort of a junior leader
to being a more senior leader.
And all of those have different steps,
different sort of stakeholders
across the organization.
And you do kind of like you said,
for many engineers,
they transition from being
a great engineer
to now having a role
of managing engineers.
And there's just such a different
sort of almost skill set.
And the same is true, of course,
in data and analytics,
which is to say
there's a certain skill set
which involves being able to wrangle
a bunch of data,
being able to clean
or tease insights out of data
or communicate with data.
I think actually,
I would actually probably
have the opposite because
when you're an analytics leader,
you're trying to tease
those same insights out of the data
and simplify it
at the sort of cross-functional level.
So, a lot of those core skills
you develop as an IC,
though the jobs aren't identical,
a lot of those sort of core skills
translate really nicely,
into the managerial world.
What do you enjoy more? Which of these?
Well, obviously, I've spent the last
sort of decade of my career leading
data teams of different sizes.
I joined Zenefits
where I led the data team
of just me
and then ultimately grew it
to a very large team
as that company
had a really meteoric scale up.
And then obviously,
most recently, before Mozart Data,
I worked at a company Eaze.
Eaze is basically a cannabis marketplace
that matches supply and demand.
It matches sort of dispensaries
with consumers that want those products.
Like any regular marketplace.
Except for [--],
because you just give the definition
of what a marketplace does and
it seems so common that
we have a marketplace for everything
from beverages, for food,
for toys or whatever.
Obviously, when it comes to cannabis
and it's still a fresh thing,
in many states, it's still something
that requires explanation.
But I'm sure it was
a phenomenal experience.
And I've actually been following
the activity of Eaze.
And I love the way
that they're democratizing
and regulating the whole transaction
in the marketplace.
But please continue.
Yeah. So, I mean,
I think actually data plays
a big, big role there.
I think when you think about
a very highly regulated market,
some of the challenges become
actually addressing that regulation,
but doing so really quickly
and understanding
what really matters to your customer.
Right.
And very often data can tease that out.
We can learn how important prices
to the customer,
how important delivery time is
how many, you know,
I think a big part of any marketplace
is understanding that balance
of supply and demand
and how to not just like,
forecast it, but also act against it.
So, data plays a huge role
in what it does.
And it was a really
forward thinking investment
to build out a strong data capability
because that was, you know,
in some sense it's forward thinking,
on the other hand,
it's just us catching up
to other industries.
You know, you mentioned
sort of food delivery, right?
Looking like many of these
are solved problems.
Transportation, obviously,
the matching of supply and demand
that Uber and Lyft do.
These are all very solve problems
in those industries
and kind of what a key role
data plays at those places,
just being able to map that
to a place with
a ton of regulatory challenges,
this is cannabis, I think is
has been and will continue
to be a really interesting data
and managerial problem for a while.
It's pretty inspiring to me
that a company like Eaze goes in
and takes an economist
and somebody that runs
that heads analytics data science teams
and puts in the position
of a chief strategy officer.
Because it really it is saying something.
It's saying that
we believe that our core strategy
should be guided by data
and by, you know,
the causality and by a team
that knows how to manage this data
and run the analytics.
I don't think that most companies
have necessarily that persona
as the chief strategy officer.
I might be wrong,
but I haven't seen that often.
So, I agree with you.
But I think the trend is that.
So, when you think about
sort of marketing,
you've traditionally seen a lot of CMOs.
But you start to see growth leaders.
Now, growth tends to be
just quantitative marketing, right?
Now, similarly, on the operations side,
when you think about solving a problem,
like, how much demand
do we expect to have
in say, San Francisco
on a Tuesday afternoon at 3PM,
ultimately, this is a data problem,
but it's also a people problem.
You have to have
the right number of people
sort of there to essentially connect
the supply and demand.
So, on the one hand, to me,
that kind of strategy work
is ultimately just data problems.
But you can see operations,
you know, business operations
and operations just looking
more and more like data problems
and having more and more
savvy data leaders
come into leadership roles
in those functions,
as well as the expectation for anybody
that's a COO,
that's a VP of operations,
is that they're comfortable working,
certainly in a BI tool,
but also having a good grasp of data
and what's happening with their data.
And I think that's a perfectly way
into what Mozart Data does.
So, having that grasp,
having that handle on all those different
data and what you can do,
talk to me a little bit about
what Mozart Data does.
And I'm particularly interested to hear
really tangibly, what insights
you've gained from, you know,
these years of both being
the data handler and the data manager,
transitioning into your new baby,
Mozart Data.
Yeah. Thanks.
And it's actually, like you said,
a very relevant segue.
Because what Dan, my co-founder and I saw
was that there was
this growing population
of folks that were really
competent and comfortable
and itching to use the data.
Like this population
of business analysts,
sales ops, marketing ops,
business ops, heads of analytics,
data analysts that really knew
what they wanted from their data,
had a great understanding
of the business definitions
and understanding of what data
would inform those business decisions.
But getting at that data,
which is now getting
more and more siloed
by all the different sort of
bevy of tools that people are using,
people are using all these
different SaaS tools and databases
that all basically siloed that data
that it's producing.
So, there's this sort of imbalance
where the demand for data
is growing really rapidly
and the supply, we know where it is,
but it's hard to get at.
You typically have to hire engineers
or data engineers
to essentially enable
that centralization of data.
And this was becoming a problem.
And more and more companies,
they hire folks like me
or like Dan to actually go
centralize that data
so that it can be used
across the organization.
And a lot of that centralizing work
is in my mind,
sort of road or commodities.
And we would just go
from company to company,
all the ones that you mentioned
in my career, building out either
the same stack
or something very, very similar,
sort of centralizing everything
in a powerful data warehouse,
a column or data warehouse.
And we decided
to essentially build that
as a service so that really anybody
that's really comfortable with data
and data thinking
and sequel could really
do the data cleaning
and the extracting,
loading and transforming of the data
that needs to be done
with their skill set,
with their understanding
of the business definitions,
of their technologies,
and not needing Python, Jinja,
DAGs, custom languages
to really make all of the work
that is actually quite straightforward
what data you need
making that available
without kind of a big data engineering.
So, what we try to do is
be the easiest way
to onboard sort of a modern data stack.
That's so interesting.
So, would an interesting
workflow be that led to that
there's somebody in marketing
that has a ton of data
and CSVs that they get
from somewhere within their company.
They load that data to you.
You help automatically cleaning it
and starting to see some causality
and some models out of them
and provide them a framework
for analyzing the data
without having to use things
like code or data science.
Well, so, I want to back it up one step.
So, you've already gotten to a point
where the marketer
has that data in CSV form.
I want the marketer to be using
the tools that they're comfortable in.
Maybe that's HubSpot
or maybe they're using Salesforce
or maybe they're using Google ads
or Facebook ads,
and we want to be able for them
with just the credentials,
just the rights
to be able to use that data,
to be able to extract and load that
into a central data warehouse.
Now, they might also have CSVs
or G-Sheet or something like that,
which they also want
to put in their data warehouse.
They want to combine
and clean this all and transform it all
in their data warehouse.
And they can do that
with a platform like Mozart.
Now, going all the way to the end,
we are actually not in the BI space.
So, we don't give you the tooling
to go graphically represent your data
and tell a story with your data.
Which is, like I mentioned,
from my time with the Eagles
and then throughout my career,
a really important part
of what a great data person does,
they tell a story with the answer.
And that's not really what we provide,
that we actually really like giving
customers a good push in the back
in terms of these are core tables,
these are core piece
of analysis that like
we see a lot of folks in the space
that you're in doing.
So, we like to give people frameworks
for doing the cleaning,
for building their analysis.
But really, what we want to do
is empower you to get to that point
of a central warehouse
where you can start joining data
from different tools,
and we want to really make that
available to anyone.
I love that. Peter, before we go,
I have to thank you for being generous
with your time
and for joining me in this show.
I have two last questions
that I have to ask.
First of all, chief bacon officer
of Bacon Hot Sauce.
Now, you've been there for 10 years.
So, I'm guessing this is going to,
it's a little different from the rest.
Yeah.
So, Bacon Hot Sauce
was a real passion project.
So, actually, Dan,
the co-founder of Mozart and I,
started this Hot Sauce company
10 years ago.
We had the idea
that the two best things in the world
were bacon and hot sauce,
and we had to combine them
and then we made that a reality.
And then ran that business for 10 years.
And actually, we ended up selling
the business and starting Mozart.
So, there's like sort of like a lie,
which is to say, like
there's a story about Slack,
which is they were a tiny speck,
and then suddenly, you know,
that wasn't going where
they wanted it to go.
So, they decided to pivot
into their chat app.
We sort of tell the story
it's only partially true,
which is we had a hot sauce company
that was failing
and that we needed to pivot.
So, we pivoted into
this Mozart Data company,
which is true in so far as that
it's Dan and I are
working on it together,
but we're sort of data
people at our core,
but also bacon and hot sauce people
also at our core.
And Peter, I have to say that
I feel like I've wasted 20 minutes.
Because I want to go back
and just talk about
this bacon hot sauce company.
But we'll leave that for another episode
in another cycle.
Before we leave, Peter,
I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Sure.
So, number one is like, efficient.
So, I love when people are able
to make great 80-20
like trade offs.
There's so much of the insight
I think, comes in kind of just the setup
and understanding of it.
I guess another one that I sort of,
you know, as a single word,
it's sort of like a pay-it-forward.
But I think one of those,
There is hyphens in there.
Yeah. Sure.
So, pay it forward
is what I found in the valley
is that so much of my growth
can be attributed
to folks that I've worked with,
both that were above me,
that worked for me,
and that were actually,
I guess, horizontal to me.
So, I think when you invest
in having those people understand
either data
or how you're thinking about the data
or how you're thinking about the problem
that pays huge dividends.
Then last year, we have a
big mentality around growth
at Mozart, professional growth,
personal growth, all of those things.
And I think growth, obviously,
my career at parts was working
in sort of growth marketing,
but I think growth is also another one
that's a little bit counterintuitive.
Which is ,the more someone grows
it doesn't distract them
from the core of what they're doing.
It actually, there is no substitution.
It actually just adds more and more
and more richness to their capabilities
and also their willingness
to invest in something.
So, sort of growth ties nicely
with pay it forward.
Peter, thank you very much.
This is wonderful.
Congratulations on your recent
four million dollar seed round
for Mozart Data.
I told you before
that I'm already upset
that we did this
a couple of weeks too late
because I wish
we could have gotten in there.
But really, congratulations.
And I love your take on things.
And particularly I get inspired
by people's journeys
where they become,
they experience
these growing pains over,
over shared experiences,
eventually culminating
in this aha moment
that they have internally
and then bring it out to the world.
So, thank you for the
inspiration for that.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Same to you.
I enjoyed it.